shawn mendes is putting his mental
health first and cancelling the rest of
his tour it's such an up and down kind
of spike earlier this month fans were
left wondering when sean's tour would
resume after he revealed he needed to
push pause for three weeks to focus on
his well-being but now he's announced
that the tour is cancelled completely
and reveals why in a lengthy statement
sean writes being on the road isn't easy
and he wasn't prepared for the toll it
took on him when the tour started he
explains quote it has become more clear
that i need to take the time i've never
taken personally to ground myself and
come back stronger we were hopeful that
i might be able to pick up with the rest
of the dates after some much needed time
off but at this time i have to put my
health as my first priority i really
learned that learn that
tour
is is this one half of the of the
picture with uh with my career and and
what i'm so in love with
and it's it's touring and it's and it's
making music and when i'm left with just
one there's always this feeling of
emptiness and though he won't be back on
stage he promises new music is coming i
promise i promise guys and now seems
shawn's using his time off for some
much-deserved r r earlier this week he
was all smiles enjoying a day at the
beach yeah that's him shirtless and
barefoot taking a stroll alongside the
boardwalk looking like there's nothing
holding him back
that lyric seems to be a theme for sean
back in april he gave fans a glimpse
into his mindset in a twitter message he
admitted quote i'm afraid that if people
know and see the truth they might think
less of me they might become bored of me
sean explained he constantly feels like
he's either flying or drowning it's a
real thing that's happening to people
sean also noted that the public's
perception of him sometimes plays a part
in his anxiety struggles the truth is
even with so much success i still find
it hard to feel like i'm not failing and
pushing through that is something he's
been working on for years i think the
main thing for me is i've grown up and
be kind of just become a lot more
just
cool and happy with being in my body and
myself and what i'm talking about and
you know i'm not i'm not as worried
about what people think as much the
musician ended his post by sharing his
wish that his words will resonate with
his fans
i put my story out there and i hope
people can kind of connect with it and
use it
for them in october fans will hear
shawn's voice in a whole new way
[Music]
yup sean's a singing croc in the
animated film lyle lyle crocodile
someone who's looking forward to meeting
him one day his co-star constance wu you
know he just
sings so i didn't get to meet him
but i can't wait
we have the same voice teacher too so
yeah i'm excited he's awesome
you